good morning Hank it's Monday January
4th 2010 I have a bit of a toothache
today actually that's an understatement
I have a tooth what is it after hurts so
bad so I'm gonna go to the dentist so
Hank today I want to talk about rules
I've been thinking about rules a lot
lately because the reason I have a tooth
and I heard so bad is because I failed
to follow the rules of basic dental
hygiene when I was in high school in
college you see at the time I believe
that the rule you have to brush your
teeth at least twice a day was a
conspiracy by the toothpaste companies
created to sell more toothpaste
combine that with the fact that for ten
years I didn't go to a dentist because
of course I'm afraid of dentists because
I have most of the major phobias and you
get that terrible moment when in 2002 I
finally went to a dentist only to learn
that I had more cavities than I have
teeth that ever gets old but that does
it's like torture so that was fun I have
to get a root canal tomorrow possibly
two root canals if I'm lucky
so my failure to follow the rules of
Dentistry is coming back to haunt me I
had the same problem with math and many
other things like when I was in high
school I believed that math was created
arbitrarily for the purpose of making me
suffer it never crossed my mind that the
government was investing in my education
because it's helpful to have citizens
who know how to do long division I
thought that math was just a conspiracy
by the man to keep people like me down
by the way I'm going to get lunch at
Whole Foods I'm getting runchy sushi for
lunch
of course it turns out that math is
hugely helpful to adults even if you
write books for a living but even still
Hank for much of my life I've had a
terrible time following the rules
because I have deep down believed that
the rules are arbitrary and meaningless
like on some level that's always felt
like I'm doing the 110 meter hurdles and
I'm running and I'm hurdling and I'm
running and hurdling and then I begin to
think this race would go so much faster
if we just eliminated the hurdles under
professional hurdlers ever think that if
they ever think you know this is fun but
I could do it faster if we took out
their hurdles no of course they don't
think that because professional hurdlers
have respect for the utility of rules
Hank rules are all that stand between us
and chaos and endless root canals that's
why I now brush my teeth regularly and
that's why our video blog needs rules
rule number one Hank every Monday
Wednesday and Friday for the entirety of
2010 you and I will make videos
and forth to each other well that's a
little bit weird so you'll make a video
on Wednesday I'll make one on Friday
you'll make one on Monday etc until the
year is over with exceptions a for major
holidays and B for my paternity leave
which will commence whenever the kid is
born which should be quite soon and will
last about three weeks rule to these
videos shall not exceed four minutes in
length except for the usual exceptions
rule 3 whoever has the Monday video can
announce a theme for that week if there
is a theme week announced by the way
this week no theme the videos for that
week must be on that theme and lastly
rule 4 if any of the three previous
rules are broken there will be a
punishment because Hank in this world
there are consequences like root canals
and not knowing how to do wrong Division
I know how to carry items but I don't
know how to carry numbers punishments
will be chosen by nerdfighters and the
other brother and they must be completed
within one week of being assigned which
by the way Hank means that you have one
week from today to spend 15 hours in a
target and I still owe a punishment as
well which you still haven't given me
but once you do I'll have a week to
complete it so Hank them's the rules
they exist to help us remember to be
awesome here's to a great year Hank Oh
Oh horse on my tools